hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar analysis of surface
antigens on exosomes using in vitro gen
attune and xt flow cytometer I'm Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific thermo Fisher is a world
leader in serving science whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers in or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits
tab located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits
I now present today's speaker Steve
McClellan the manager of basic and
translational research operations at the
University of South Alabama Mitchell
Cancer Institute he also serves as chief
of the flow cytometry core laboratory
Steve has more than 30 years of
expertise and advanced flow cytometry
and self sorting he has worked in basic
and clinical research in the areas of
cancer biology stem cell therapy
transplant immunology and
xenotransplantation for the past 12
years his lab has been conducting
research on cancer stem cells and
circulating tumor cells the aim is to
develop better methods of purification
culture and analysis at both genetic and
functional levels and using cancer stem
cells in high-throughput screening drug
discovery exosomes are the latest
addition to the labs research efforts
his complete bio is found on the lab
roots website Steve McClelland will now
begin his presentation
thank you I would like to share with you
on some of our recent progress and using
the attune NXT to analyze surface
markers on exosomes some of the first
published reports on exosomes date back
to the mid 80s and the field actually
began in the world of platelet biology
and reticulocyte maturation since that
time the number of references in
publications talking about exosomes has
grown exponentially around the turn of
the millennium is when we see the first
reports of using flow cytometry to
actually looks at exosomes and in the
last five to ten years we've seen yet
another explosion in those publications
due to the improvements in the
sensitivity of our instruments and also
highly defined protocols to add rigor to
this what I consider to be a rather
challenging field um so let's talk about
exosomes and microvesicles
these are actually vesicular particles
that are shed from cells comprised of a
lipid bilayer and containing
representative cytosolic content from
their cell of origin
this can be DNA RNA especially micro
RNAs and proteins exons have been shown
to affect intracellular communication I
think early on they were actually
considered to be garbage bags people
thought that the exosomes were being
used as a way to shed extracellular
debris and in waste products but we now
know without much doubt that this is how
cells communicate with each other we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
on the surface markers on these small
exosomes can also be representative from
the cell of origin matching some of the
same epitopes on the surface of the cell
a voyage we generally consider exosomes
to be the smallest of these particles
ranging in size from 30 to 150
nanometers on the next larger portion of
this fraction of vesicles are what we
call
mvs or just microvesicles and those are
going to range in size from about a
hundred and fifty to a thousand
nanometers
last ten years exosomes have been
implicated in just a myriad of different
disease processes almost every disease
process has had some type of work
looking at the exosomes related to it um
we work on cancer but especially in
cancer exosomes are very critical we now
know that cancer cells secrete upwards
of 20 times more micro particles than do
normal healthy cells and in the setting
of cancer these actually have direct
effects on the healthy target cells that
they bind to once shed from the cancer
cell doing a myriad of things promoting
growth and metastasis vascular ization
of the new growth of the tumor and also
most importantly contributing to immune
suppression we have evidence that the
exosomes leave the tumor cells and
actually interact with the t-cells to
try and dampen some of the immune
response
so this little cartoon kind of depicts
two different ways of how these are
formed so the larger microvesicles
actually bud off of the surface
literally pinch off and just release
away from this cell hence they're much
bigger true exosomes are developed
through an endo siddik process so small
clathrin-coated pits actually invaginate
from the exterior of the membrane
forming what we call an early endosome
that little packet matures into then
what we call a multi vesicular endosome
and at that point those exosomes can
either be released back to the surface
if that mve is actually directed to fuse
back to the membrane and just free reeve
agitate I guess you'd say and then
expose the exosomes to the exterior
surface or lysosomes will bind on to
that to to destroy the contents of the
MV
so there are several ways to isolate
exosomes
we'll start with precipitation well let
me start by saying that there are really
two primary sources that you're going to
use to isolate exosomes for basic
research you can easily use culture
supernatant bells grown in culture
constantly shed exosomes it can be a
very nice clean source to look at
specific markers or micro rna's of
interest there's a variety of body
fluids that people have excellent
isolated exosomes from urine blood which
would be really plasma and that
distinction is important clotted blood
which would be referred to as serum is
not a good product to use many of the
exosomes get trapped in the in the
clotting process and so your yield would
be far lower if you used serum versus
plasma they've been found in saliva
cerebral spinal fluid just about any
fluid and body is going to have exosomes
in it so you can precipitate these there
are in the last five years especially
we've seen a explosion of kits on the
market that actually allow you to
precipitate these small vesicles
in our hands these kids don't provide
very good purity um they're quick
usually within an hour you can isolate
the little particles but we've seen that
they might not even be suitable purity
for even doing Western blots um we
certainly have not had any success using
precipitation kits for purifying them to
do flow side Americ analysis they seem
to be very sticky after whatever
chemicals are used to do that
precipitation so pretty much the only
thing we found them useful for was
really working towards DNA or RNA
isolation at the end of that process
the size-exclusion filtration can happen
in two ways you can use membranes with a
known pore size say 100 micron to do the
filtering out the largest vesicles and
then the exosomes smaller than 100
microns would come down through the
nanometers excuse me would come through
we've played with this a little bit arm
it they tend to clog pretty quick and so
I don't think it's a very time efficient
way of doing it I think if you're really
going to do size-exclusion the best way
would be through chromatography small
columns with some sort of chromatography
material in it that really can just do
size exclusion so the smallest particles
run through first and you collect
fractions and those can provide very
high purity sometimes you worried that
you might not get full recovery so your
yield might be a little lower in that
method um and it certainly never be
considered quantitative because each
sample might not
travel through the the chromatography
bed quite the same but they do come out
very clean in that respect so we like
that for flow cytometry
the olden days when people first started
trying to do flow cytometry amino
affinity beads were really the way that
everybody did this so small magnetic or
polystyrene beads coated with specific
antibodies that bind exosomes we'll talk
a little bit more about these markers
later CD 9 CD 63 and CD 81 that capture
and and localize the exosomes onto the
beads you can then wash and have a very
pure preparation you could go directly
to isolating the DNA RNA or proteins
from those exosomes at that step or you
could use more antibodies to label the
surface of those exosomes that are now
immobilized onto the bead and do flow
cytometry and that's really what they
were aiming for before the flow
cytometry came sensitive enough to
actually resolve the individual
particles um which we'll get to in just
a second but you know in the early days
you really could only see small beads on
the flow cytometry and that was really
the only way you could qualitatively
assess what was on the surface of an
exosome by using the bead capture method
we and many others consider differential
centrifugation to be probably the best
way to isolate exosomes at least with
very good purity
it's highly time-consuming as you can
see on the right there is a set of
successive spins so each preparation
will take a minimum of six hours really
if you push right through it um you can
do several well I can't do too many
because most of the centrifuges only
have safe tubes in them so you can only
process six things at once so it is
time-consuming but in our burrs on our
hands this provides probably the most
pure product that we can work with
especially when we're looking at doing
flow cytometry where they're not left
with any kind of sticky coating and then
we don't get too much nonspecific
antibody binding
as we go through each faster spin you
generate the different levels so first
we're going to rule out the cell and
cell debris particles at the first spin
the large vesicles from the second spin
are considered a pop tonic bodies and
another type of Vesco called a large
Uncas ohm we're not going to talk too
much about those today the next 16,500 G
spin generates the medium-sized what we
would consider microvesicles in that
five 150 to 1000 nanometer range then we
take that supernatant put it in this
ultra centrifuge for two hours and those
are the Oxus ohms the small vesicles
that are actually in that range of 30 to
150 nanometers leftover juice is really
just soluble material there's not much
left after the ultra centrifugation spin
in the super named
so early on when we started working with
exosomes and try to do flow cytometry
with them we came up with an idea to use
ultra filtered solutions to reduce the
burden of debris in those solutions that
we use to prepare the exosomes and also
in the actual focusing fluid or sheath
fluid that runs through the flow
cytometry which helps us to improve
background noise traditionally sheath
fluid is only filtered down to about a
hundred nanometer particle size and
that's roughly the same size as exosomes
by using a say PE s membrane that has
only 30 nanometer pores and that way all
of the solutions really don't have any
debris particulates that are larger than
the size of the particle we're looking
for um we believe and we've noticed a
huge significant difference in
sensitivity of the instrument when we
were able to do this ultra filtration
and think that it's really a key point
in making this much more successful
so once you've done whatever method
you're going to do to isolate your
vesicles and exosomes you need to be
able to
want to take really what size particle
you've you've isolated you've got to
make sure that what you're calling a
nexus ohm is truly the right size there
are several ways to do this
unfortunately all of them involve use of
yet another instrument on to to judge
size probably the most part popular at
this point in time is nt a nano particle
tracking analysis these instruments
actually use a laser to illuminate the
particles in solution but it's an
imaging based system so it actually
watches them the the vesicles move
around in solution and it's using the
old-style technique of Brownian motion
so the laws of physics that recover
Brownian motion are how it develops
algorithms to actually calculate the
size of the exosomes it's very quick and
it can also at the same time give you a
relative concentration of the number of
particles per milliliter so like I said
that's pretty much become one of the
most popular systems to use for sizing
exosomes these days
a newer version of a sizer is tbrs tres
resistive pulse sensing it's a mouthful
is actually based on the old Coulter
principle of sizing particles just on
the nano scale so in this method a
membrane has a very small nano meter
hole in it and every time a particle
crosses through it an electrical charge
is developed from one side to the other
side of the membrane and that is
responsive to the size of the particle
highly accurate it also gives you a very
accurate method of concentration these
instruments have been around that long
and I think that over time they're
probably going to overtake NTA because
in my opinion I think they're probably
quite a bit more
DLS dynamic light scattering is also a
laser based system the nano particles
are in suspension the laser hits and as
light diffracts off of and scatters off
of the particles there are a number of
different detectors at different angles
that are able to calculate the size
based on the type and light scatter
pattern these are also considered to be
pretty accurate but the problem with DLS
is that does not give you any kind of
idea of the concentration of the
particles in the solution
and last but not least the gold standard
if you want to measure the size of
something you look with an electron
microscope and that's true for exosomes
as well traditionally transmission
electron microscopy TEM has been used
the newer modality of cryo am is
probably better it helps preserve the
structure a little better but either
work fine and really many people want
you to at least show that to make sure
that you're correlating and the other
instruments that you've used actually
are are accurate so we do from time to
time submit samples for en just to
double-check and make sure we're on
track with everything quickly I'll
mention I think I will say it later but
here at our Center we used Els for
sizing our necks
so let's talk briefly about the attune
NXT um this is kind of a different beast
um the attune NXT is the only system on
the market that uses acoustic waves to
actually focus the cells into a very
tight and uniform line as they flow past
the laser interrogation point all other
flow cytometer 'z use the tried-and-true
principle of hydrodynamic focusing which
uses high-pressure sheath going through
the flow cell which causes a swirly
effect kind of and forces those cells
into a tight line um when you look at
acoustic focusing versus hydrodynamic
focusing you can achieve much tighter
peaks v's um compared to traditional
Saitama terms it really is aligning
those particles much more precisely as
they cross through the laser beam um and
another advantage of the hydrodynamic
focusing is that it gives us very very
discreet control over the speed with
which our particles are flowing past the
laser beam so
benefit of that is that the attune can
actually process samples much faster
than just about any other site ometer on
the market for us the flipside of that
is that we can now slow them way down we
run at the very slowest dynamic rate
which is 12.5 microliters per minute of
sample injection through the laser beam
and what that allows us to do is
actually increase maximize the dwell
time that each little particle spends as
it crosses that laser beam so the slower
you go the longer and of course we're
talking microseconds but it's enough to
make a difference in the amount of
photons that can be captured off so it
really does running slower in this
system really does increase the
sensitivity in that you can collect more
photons from each particle and be a
brighter signal
so not only do we have the fluidics part
but the attune does have barely
high-powered lasers
it can provide 50 milli watts on the 405
48 and 561 nanometer lines and 100 milli
watts at the far red 647 line and it
does that in combination with something
called the flat top beam shaping optics
another mouthful really what that means
is that instead of focusing the laser
into a very tight spot which the cells
may or may not correctly intersect the
laser beam is actually 10 nanometer
about 50 nanometer wide so what it means
is that the alignment of the instrument
is almost irrelevant because the the
particle will always be crossing the
maximum width of that laser which also
helps with the sensitivity we're talking
about and just makes it more robust
so
our collaboration that we've done with
our friends at thermo Fisher and the
infusion headquarters in Eugene Oregon
have been assisting them to evaluate new
bandpass filters and we've been able to
come up with a different filter that is
normally supplied with the original
instrument in front of the side scatter
detector and this has greatly increased
the significance weight excuse me
greatly increased the sensitivity of the
system I think that we and others in
this collaborative effort have come to
an agreement that the new bandpass
filter really does make a huge
difference and as I mentioned before on
the previous slide the ultra filtering
of the focusing fluid really does
dramatically increase decrease the
background noise that we see in
in running samples
so how
we validate that a flow cytometer can
actually see exosomes
quality control material at this point
in time primarily exists of micro
particle beads um just like any other
beads that you would use to assess the
performance of your flow cytometer but
in this case they're much smaller um
presently the industry standard is
considered to be the a pudgy flow
systems beads called a poaching mix they
consist of a range of six silica
particles and two polystyrene particles
which actually have green fluorescence
embedded into them
um the
between silica and polystyrene is that
still occur has the material itself has
a refractive index closest to what the
refractive index of true vesicular
particles are so it's really considered
to be the best closest reference
standard particle that we can use we
also use the bio Scitex megamix
particles they are also polystyrene with
some fluorescence embedded and we
actually like to mix those two on this
histogram you can see that the top two
peaks are the apg polystyrene beads
I'll first start off by saying we
generally do not see those matching any
size of any other particle I'm not sure
why we basically just kind of ignore
those but when you move down to the
megamix polystyrene beads you can see a
three populations of five hundred nine
hundred or three thousand nanometers
which is almost off scale
and the red boxes indicate that those
polystyrene beans actually line up
pretty well with the similar size silica
particles so the 500 Ana meter megamix
lines up with the 590 nanometers select
a particle from the apg beads
similarly the 800 to 880 sometimes we
don't always resolve that 1300 nanometer
still like the particles and as we see
it sometimes we don't we're not really
sure why
but again I don't really care because
I'm worse than on what's going on to the
left of that so from that point on to
500 then we resolved the next smallest
which is it 300 go to 240 we've got the
180 so around the 10 to the 4th hash
mark is where we're starting to see
those smallest particles and that's
going to be the range that we would
expect to see exosomes appear when we
run them on the site ometer much below
10 to the 4th is really pretty much
considered electronic noise the large
orange portion in the corner is probably
the electronic noise and then perhaps
that next cloud over would be our 30
nanometer background particles after
doing the ultra filtration
so as long as the beads look good I say
yes I think my cytometer can see small
particles well let's test that so we're
going to make some exosome fractions and
do our successful our successive ultra
fugate ultra centrifugation spins and
far-left
you can see where we've run just 500
microliters of ultra filtered PBS again
small amount of electronic noise that's
run at a threshold setting of 200 and
generally we move that threshold up to
about 500 which is where that red line
is indicating so that we can not count
noise particles and then the rest would
just be the 30 nanometer or less debris
zone in that PBS when we run exomes on
the next panel over we see that they are
pretty much in that very small zone of
what we would hope to be 30 to 150
nanometers and for just points of
reference there's very little in that
gate on the right the next larger spin
microvesicles obtained from 16,500 show
the concentration in this density plot
moving to the right so we're getting
bigger up to about 33 percent in that
right gate then our apop topic bodies
which were the first span at only 2000 g
shift that density plot even further to
the right now we're at about 54% so not
only do we have confidence that we're
seeing the exosomes but the other things
that we know to be in an appropriate
size range are all falling into pretty
much the correct sized zone so when we
see things like this we have fairly good
confidence that the instrument is being
individual exosomes and they're putting
them on scale pretty much in the right
spot in correlation to our reference
beads
next we have to make sure that the
instrument is actually analyzing
individual exosomes this is critical
many of our preps get highly diluted on
the range of anywhere from 1 to 100
sometimes up to 1 to 10,000 depending on
how concentrated these preparations are
made we generally take the pellets from
the ultracentrifuge spin and we suspend
it in a fairly small volume which means
that we then have to do pretty large
delusions to get to the point where we
want to do this kind of flow cytometry
work to validate that we aren't seeing
what we call a swarm effect which would
be multiple particles coming through the
interrogation point of the laser at the
same time by doing this simple dilution
series so we they make a starting 1 to
100 dilution run it and see that we get
50 7-eleven counts per second successive
1 to 2 delusions of that with
ultra-filtered PBS in theory should cut
that in half so the number in the center
is the number that we actually acquire
and then a theoretical number on the
letter far-right corresponds to half
that number
half of 2 7 11 and then you just kind of
cut those in half and you'll see it does
match fairly well um I'm sure that there
are probably some acceptance criteria
that of you know what percent variance
can you accept this tolerable to me
something like this looks perfectly fine
that gives me perfect confidence that we
literally are putting only one particle
past the laser at a time and that's been
one of the biggest problems in cytometry
so now we're able to actually resolve
these individual particles we got to
make sure that we have our sample
diluted enough that they literally are
going by one at a time this is a
critical critical quality control step
that we do with every single exosome
prep that we make
you
so now I guess we need to figure out
what we're going to do with these
exosomes what are we going to look for
um we've got one more little quality
control step to go through though
when you do this ultra centrifugation
stab you do get some other things
pelleting the sides
besides exosomes so these might be small
protein aggregates but we've got to be
able to exclude what would be true
debris in that final spin versus true
lipid bilayer vesicular particles we do
that using a lipophilic dye which is
going to allow us to really say that's a
vesicle that's not and make that
decision so we have tried a lot we've
settled on a product from thermo Fisher
known as FM 143 and FM 464 these are
lipophilic sterile dyes that have the
ability to interpolate into the outer
leaf of the membrane my favorite part of
this molecule is that it's not
fluorescent until they actually
intercalate into that outer membrane
similar to like a DNA dye binding into a
DNA strand so what this especially has
allowed us to do is to develop a no wash
staining protocol so we can add enough
of this dye to stain but it's not enough
to cause problems with anything else the
debris particles will not pick it up and
so this has become our favorite
our favorite dye to use for this
lipophilic ID
the key point of trying to develop a no
wash staining protocol is that every
wash takes about at least two and a half
hours by the time the ultracentrifuge
comes up to speed you spend for two
hours and you spin it down there's no
such thing as a quick wash when you deal
with the exosomes
so we've worked very hard on trying to
develop our no wash staining protocol
there's other lipophilic dyes you can
use but dip EPR ceramide is actually
just a lipid molecule with a fluorescent
tag bound on to it that will also
interpolate into the
membrane of the vesicle
one thing I think I just realized I
forgot to tell you is that the FM one -
43 is excited by a 488 Anna Miller laser
and it emits its light in the 525 -
about 625 nanometer range fits into the
PE area ah
and then FM 4 - 64 needs green the 561
nanometer laser excitation and it's
going to emit further down in the red
range 700 to about 700 nanometers so you
have two different color options there
to choose as you also look for what
antibody markers you want
we always do this in combination with
antibody staining the Bo dippy is
actually only available in one color it
uses 561 excitation and emits light in
range of 575 to about 625 we have not
really tried this with or without
washing
it may be possible to use that one as
well without washing but we have not
validated that
the other options the di series which
are actually carbo cyanide carbo cyanine
membrane dyes have been widely used for
many many years as membrane labelers to
do in vivo cell tracking cell mixing
cell fusion experiments that have been
used for many years as well as pkh dyes
which are similarly able to interpolate
into the outer membrane and PTH has
actually been made into a whole rainbow
of colors I think there's actually eight
different fluorescent molecules across
the whole span of the range that a
centimeter can detect the big problem
with these two kinds of dyes is that you
require multiple washes to get rid of
all of the excess dye there they're
really kind of a pain to deal with it's
what we started with we started with the
PK age and one of actually one of my
students was reading through a paper and
saw the reference to the fm1 - 43 and we
ordered it and tried it and it was like
okay
never again so um so that's where we
stand we believe that's probably your
best choice but there are many options
there um once you're going to do that
staining now we're now we can say what's
to bring what's a true lipophilic
tential exosome
now we're going to use antibodies to
look at three gold standard reference
molecules those being CD 9d B 63 and CD
81 you cannot call a particle and
exosome unless it has at least one of
those markers on the surface let me
repeat that
if you don't see at least one of those
three CD markers on the surface of the
exosome you cannot call it a nexus so
these are fluorescently directly
conjugated antibodies and we'll talk a
little bit more about the way we do this
so as I said we've got a no wash
protocol so we are able to actually even
though we do DLS to measure the size of
our our exosomes another benefit of the
attune NXT site ometer is that it uses
volumetric counting so it can give us a
fairly accurate concentration of the
particles in there so when we're doing
those dilution tests we're also kind of
validating what the actual particle
concentration per milliliter is in that
particular sample so knowing that number
we aim to put about 250,000 exosomes in
250 microliters of ultra filtered PBS we
generally just use standard 12 by 75
polystyrene Beck's tubes um we add our
FM 143 dye at a final concentration of
0.5 micro molar then we add our
antibodies according to the titrated
optimum concentration which is generally
somewhere between the range of 50 to 200
nanograms per mil we incubate that
sample at room temperature for 10
minutes and then immediately place them
on ice and try to run them on the site
ometer as fast as possible
it's a fairly straightforward staining
protocol and we've done a lot of work to
optimize that trust me
titration of your antibodies is very
important as it is in all aspects of
flow cytometry one must really titrate
your antibodies to two good work
so this is an example of what the
lipophilic dye looks like center panel
unstained exosomes I've popped up the
reference of the beads just to kind of
show you that we are in that range
around that 10 to the 4th hash mark
threshold was set a little higher when
these samples were collected but we are
right there in that size zone for
exosomes then this gate on the right is
going to actually show you the particles
a good percentage of the group 84% on
that one um
when you see some variability so you
could go anywhere from 50% on the low
end up to maybe 90% on the high end
using differential centrifugation of the
purity and that's why we do all of these
QC steps for every single preparation we
make differences in of course what the
samples starts from be it cultural
supernatant versus a body fluid but even
just you would consider fairly uniform
culture supernatant can provide
different purities in preparation so
it's really important to do all of these
upfront QC s on every single preparation
we use this positive gate on the right
to then look at antibodies so we'll get
from here to the next panel which is
going to show us a three color stain now
we always use ISO type controls matched
ISO type controls to make sure that
these exosomes aren't too sticky as I
think I mentioned if you times earlier
the precipitation kits would provide
such sticky exosomes that the isotypes
were as bright if not brighter and the
marker of interest antibodies that we
were using and so when we first started
seeing that we realized well okay we
can't use precipitation kids because the
staining is meaningless so by using ISO
type controls we can set these mods
dance then look at the expression of our
three reference gold markers top right
panel shows that almost 90% of the
exosomes in this preparation that were
also positive for FM one - 43 so this is
dated from that positive lipid gate are
expressing 63 and 81 the bottom panel
when you do 81 versus nine the nine
isn't is strong properly about that's
probably about 60% have crossed that
threshold arm again every prep can show
high variability in how much of each of
those markers are there sometimes you
don't have any on one of them you might
only have say nine and eighty one um and
we do all three because we need to
assess what that particular preparation
has on its surface um so we'll pick one
that has the preponderance in this case
we chose CB 63
then we'll do extra staining tubes with
two more markers of interest so we'll
put in our 63 antibody and in this case
we're staining exosomes that we've
isolated from the culture supernatant of
cancer cells Mia pack a cell line
actually and creati cancer cells and in
this case we're comparing cells that
were grown in two different conditions
hypoxic and norm oxic conditions so
we've done all of the spinning with all
of our culture supernatant from these
two comparative cell lines and we're
looking for the markers cd44 and CD 184
and we actually saw quite a distinct
difference in norm oxic conditions not
all happily only with the numbers here
40% of the exosomes are actually
staining positive for CD 184 they're
fairly uniform for 44 all of them have
44 on them but in normal conditions we
only see about 40% 184 positive and in
the hypoxic conditions and this is
related to cancer stem cell cancer stem
cell miss the stemness of these markers
increase in hypoxic conditions and so
now all of the exosomes are dual
positive for 44 and 180 for
our just representative figures of the
kind of data that we're generating um
one quick comment on the choice of
fluorochromes you must strive to use
only the very brightest fluorochromes
those being the polymer violet dyes like
we're in the alexa fluor dyes especially
647 it's hard to find but sometimes one
of my favorites is also alexa fluor 546
it's also one of the brightest ones um
but you really need good good strong
bright dies because exosomes are small
they're probably less than a hundredth
of the Sun or an antibody is probably
only less 1/100 of a size of a nexus ohm
so you can't really stick too many on
the surface so you need each fluorescent
molecule to give out as much light as
possible to be able to generate a signal
that you can detect
so I'd like to wrap up today
by letting me know that in my opinion
exosome flow cytometry requires vigorous
validation at several steps you have to
start off by characterizing your
instrument and making sure that your
background noise does not interfere with
being able to resolve the small silica
particles that are at this point in time
the best QC material we have I know
several companies are working hard on
generating what's going to be the next
generation of QC material which is going
to be a stabilized small vesicle in the
correct size which is going to give us
the ultimate material as a quality
control standard because they have the
same refractive index as our exosomes
but for now this tilaka micro particles
are really the best way we have of
assessing our instrument so I've shown
you that there are a variety of methods
to isolate exosomes
um I strongly encourage you to try
several of them it depends on what kind
of starting material you're using plasma
is much more dirty than say urine if
you're going to go after a bio fluid
culture supernatant pretty easy an ultra
sampling is pretty standard for that but
try-try lots of things see what in your
hands gives you the best the best result
this is not something and I have to say
this with the strongest emphasis
if you're thinking of starting working
with exosomes don't think you're just
going to try it once and get some pretty
data we've been working on this for two
years this is not a trivial undertaking
you have to be very rigorous and
methodical in the way you do things to
to really be able to prove to yourself
and then convince yourself that you are
truly seeing the correct particle um so
it's been a lot of fun and I think that
there's no question that exosomes are
the wave of the future for for potential
Diagnostics for figuring out
intracellular communication and ways to
interrupt that that might potentially
develop new diagnostic or therapeutic
effects for a myriad of diseases we are
very excited about the potential of this
we work predominantly with pancreatic
cancer patient samples here um and
that's the disease that we're going
after
I guess I'll wrap up by saying our
collaboration with the flow cytometry
team at thermo Fisher has really been
wonderful um I think that our work
together has greatly improved the
confidence that this this
next-generation Atun and xt site ometer
has the ability to t microparticles and
can reliably provide good surface
antibody staining data
and I think probably the last thing I'll
say is that the the new side scatter
filter that we've come up with will be
available in the near future it takes a
while at a big company to come up with a
new product and part number and
everything but but it's coming and you
will have access to that in the near
future
just one small simple filter to buy to
swap out on your instrument and I think
that's all I have but thank you very
much for your attention I hope it's been
beneficial and I'd be happy to entertain
any questions
Thank You fee for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
Steve McClelland will answer as many
questions as time permits first question
is what are the challenges of using
polystyrene beads and silica beads to
size standards
so you know I hate to patently endorse
one product over another but a pudgy
really is the only company offering
these small silica particles there is a
vast difference between the refractive
index of silica versus polystyrene it is
generally accepted in the field that
polystyrene does not offer a close
enough true sizing standard to judge the
size of a nexus ohm you must use the
silica particles at this point they
really are the only thing available
that's close enough to the refractive
index to really gain a true sense of
what size of particle you're resolving
in your flow cytometer and coupling that
with the ultra filtered Sun filter
filter sheet fluid really does make a
huge difference in making that
resolution happen thank you next one is
did you consider instrument resolution
limitations when designing your
experiment and what consideration should
be accounted for and considered
um
I think
really you have to start at the
beginning you have to start with the
beads and prove to yourself that your
instrument is capable of resolving those
beads I'm quite sure that some of the
stuff up told you today can be
applicable to other saitama ters as well
but until you do it yourself and prove
that you're actually resolving all of
those little simple silica particles
there's no sense in even doing any
excess home preparations um so it's it's
you can't put the cart before the horse
you have to validate that your
instrument can actually resolve things
in that 30 to 150 nanometers Ange and
the only way to do that is by easy
thank you next one is what do you see as
future directions in the exosome field
and what role can flow cytometry play
Wow
so last week I attended the American
Society of exosome and micro vesicle
National meeting in Baltimore and I was
just astounded it's been several years
since I attended that conference and I
was astounded at how many different
disease states are actually involved in
exosome work I mean everything from
Alzheimer's nerds genetic diseases of
course cancer um diabetes
restless leg syndrome I was astounded to
see their poster on restless leg
syndrome and they think that they can
now predict which Parkinson and
Huntington patients will be affected
more heavily by that just looking at an
exosome signature it was just astounding
um I have no doubt like I said earlier
that this is the wave of the future
there are so many potential uses for
these things as early diagnostic markers
predictors for potential therapy
solutions the sky's the limit and I as I
said at the very beginning if you look
at in PubMed it literally has been an X
potential growth of reports of people
looking at exosomes photometry is going
to have a much bigger field heart to
play in this field
especially if we can move towards
generating selfs orders that are more
sensitive there it has been done that's
even harder oh my gosh I can't even
imagine but if we can then push to that
point so we can now do this surface
labeling and then sort out a specific
marker on the surface and see what's
inside of maybe those exosomes
sky's the limit it's a very exciting
field decided to be in part of it
thank you next one is how are your
samples collected and were there any
time restrictions
so
um for working with culture supernatant
it's not that difficult
do you have to start which much larger
volumes to get the number of exosomes
back so on average we would do all six
places in the ultracentrifuge rotor with
50 milliliter tubes so we would try to
spin at least 300 milliliters of culture
supernatant to start with that generates
in general a pretty good
amount of exosomes to work with the
interesting thing we've noticed along
the way is that there's huge variability
in the number of exosomes that different
cell lines secrete some don't secrete
very much at all and others just make
hordes of them so that's something to
consider as well you might want to try
several different cell lines to see what
gives you the best yield to have
material to work with I think I
mentioned in the beginning we use
patient blood and that's collected in a
green top heparin tube as plasma it is
critical that you do not use the serum
because the process of letting blood
clot traps so many of the little
exosomes in the actual hard clot so that
when you just dump out the serum there's
very little exosome left in it so you
really have to use plasma
many of my colleagues use urine
especially looking at prostate cancer
that's a very nice way to isolate
exosomes because the urine is actually
pretty clean and pure of other things
and again you can use three Pro finals
fluid there's there's lots of different
things you can do one thing that we did
test early on and that we feel is very
critical for obtaining blood from
patients is that we want to stabilize
that plasma with a protease inhibitor as
fast as possible we strive to have that
tube of blood in our hands within 30
minutes of it coming out of a patient
spin it down and we need to add a
standard protease inhibitor tablet to a
certain concentration whatever
recommended I'm not even sure where we
get ours from but that's a pretty
standard thing but we've done this side
by side we've done time tests the blood
sat at 30 minutes to an hour to 4 hours
with or without protease inhibitors and
we do see a strong loss of surface
markers on the exosomes if we don't have
those protease inhibitors in there I
probably should have mentioned that in
the main part of the webinar it's very
important to have those in there to help
preserve the structure of the exosomes
great thank you for that the next one is
I'm really confused by terminology V's
versus maybe vs. X's prosper a hot topic
yeah but under terminology it's kind of
crazy um I really think it's best to
maybe go back and look at that slide
where I've got the 3 successive spin
speeds lined out and because that's the
best way to just wrap your head around
it so at each higher level of g-force
you're going to pull down a smaller and
smaller particle so the largest of these
are considered a popped Adak bodies
these are blebs that are spit out of
cells as they're undergoing the final
processes of apoptosis where the cell is
literally ready to break down um I
mentioned large uncas ohms which are
somewhat controversial in the field
actually um but those are kind of lumped
into that large category medium category
is always going to be considered a
catch-all microvesicles can be anywhere
from about a hundred and fifty up to a
thousand nanometers that's a pretty big
size range um we do believe that the the
way they're generated is pretty uniform
from the budding of the exterior of the
membrane and then a nexus ohm is never
bigger than 150 some people are a little
more strict and call that a hundred
nanometer on the on the top end on say
30 to 100 nanometers so we're pretty
confident in how those are developed as
well with the invasion ation and the
multi fascicular endosome body that then
refuses to the membrane and releases
those little particles out to the
surface
there have been groups that have done
just phenomenal live cell imaging you
can actually pre label the membrane with
some of these dyes I talked about the
lipophilic dyes and then literally over
time lapse videography watch exosomes
being released from cells in lifetime
it's a phenomenal thing so wewe know how
it works we can watch it and really you
just think about small medium and large
that's the big best way to think of it
well thank you looks like we have time
for one more question how did you
determine the optimal titer of
antibodies to use in this application
um really no different than titration of
antibodies on cells uh it's very
important to try a variety of different
concentrations what you're looking for
is a signal-to-noise ratio where if you
have antibodies at too high of a
concentration the negative cells will
kind of creep up and be brighter
optimally what you're trying to do is
and the process of titration really is
to maximize the space between the
negative and the positive population and
so when you do your titration of
different concentrations that's what you
look for and then at a certain point of
course you're going to start to drop off
your signal so you know that's gone too
far dilute um there are many many
references to talk about how to properly
do titration of antibody out there on
them and just search the web and I'm
sure you can find four or five but um
it's it's very important to try
titration with all of these epitopes
especially in our case where we were
trying to minimize the amount of
antibody to get a signal in this no wash
particle so we found that to be very
very critical can't just go adding a
whole bunch of antibody in there and not
wash it back out
thank you I would like to once again
thank Steve McClellan for his
presentation and I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through May twenty nineteen lab routes
will alert you via email and it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye